for years zanav national park in
mozambique was called to the silent park
after being devastated during a 15-year
civil war which began in the late 1970s
it was this eerie feeling of just dead
quietness there was not a bird not an
insect and not an animal in sight south
african organization peace parks
partnered with the mozambican government
to bring back wild animals and restore
the park to its former glory
it's about 400 000 hectares big trees
animals paradise
so far they've brought in lions and
leopards zebra and antelope and last but
definitely not least it's these guys
turn
black and white groaner will be the last
historical species that are yet to be
reintroduced into into xanav and
obviously by bringing the biggest
species it gets the smaller species
going the birds and the beetles
it's the first time rhinos have been in
sonar for 40 years and moving them from
south africa was no small undertaking
the organizers say it was a difficult
and expensive operation transferring
animals that can weigh up to two and a
half thousand kilograms
nineteen white rhinos made the trip
that's hoped to be the first of several
to relocate about 40 black and white
rhinos to their new home
having the political
will to reintroduce rhinos and all the
complications that come with it it's
very significant in what showing what
mozambique is prepared to do for
conservation it's a 60 to 70 hour
overland journey the longest road
transfer of rhinos ever completed the
animals were first taken across the
south african border to maputo national
park in mozambique they had two days
there to rest and rehydrate before being
reloaded and taken the rest of the way
to zanav
we have actually proved that this is
sort of a new way that we can now move
rhinos great distances across the
continent it's never been done before
and with halfway houses in the right
places we can actually restock protected
areas in in other countries a long way
away from from from us in south africa
there are only about 5 000 black rhino
left and about 18 000 white rhino to
protect them from poachers they're being
kept in a specially built high security
sanctuary within the park it's an
incredible feeling to be part of this
and to witness this this moment is
actually quite emotional
and the population has already expanded
with the arrival of this little one
alexia o'brien al jazeera